clay match diamond Barry newsgroup are
you able to describe your range of
emotions between the wind Kevin and
Kevin's injury Steve was having trouble
doing that are you able to it's tough
really it sucks man I feel so bad for
those two especially Kevin I don't know
the extent of his injury but that's
never fun man for what he did for him to
put his health on the line to come back
and compete at the highest level he's
one of the best to ever do it I want to
try to win this for him we miss him we
just hold him a speedy recovery that's
our brother and it's honestly to be to
be honest it kind of it kind of Airy
deflating it's hard to even celebrate
this win right here in the front USA
Today sports you mentioned how deflating
it is how do you guys press on from here
emotionally we do it for Kevin we do it
for K we know he I can tell you this he
wants us to compete the highest level
and we'll think of him every time we
step on the hardwood
next question was side towards the
middle shy Davidi from sports night clay
coming back from your own injury when
you saw Kevin go down there did you
think about your own status the risks
that you'd been taken in this series no
I just keep pressing on you can't be out
on the court thinking of I hope I don't
get injured that's when you get injured
so for me I just try to refocus man but
that was very deflating second row in
the middle here Mike coming your way
horizon's' posters on clay can you talk
about the Brazilian you guys show
tonight um I knew he would come out and
compete obviously having Kevin back
helps so much especially on the
offensive end you saw it there for the
first quarter this shooting was dude it
was really missed DeMarcus Cousins what
a game he came he came in and affected
the game on both sides of the ball
Stef with those timely threes and just
his ability to keep shooting even when
he sees a lot of misses he doesn't care
he's best shooter ever so he's never
going to lose confidence but I'm very
proud of the way everyone fought tonight
even going down six or three minutes
left their ball we didn't uh we didn't
panic we just do what we do mark on the
right clay mark Schwartz ESPN when Kevin
goes down in a game like that what
impact does it have on you on the floor
as you try to win a game for him
it honestly inspires you to play harder
knowing your best player can't be out
there you think of him every time you
die for loose ball or go for a rebound
because I know him and I know how bad he
must be out there that's why he was out
there and it sucks I feel so bad for him
his camp he's gonna come back stronger
though that's the kind of father it is
and I'm gonna miss some man it's not the
same being out there without him next
he'd over on the right okay Lucas Mayer
news talk 10/10 Toronto for you and
Steph 57 points combined and really kind
of taking the offensive low with Kevin
going down did you feel that you and
Steph had to with Durant going down had
to carry the load offensively so you
have many many times before and then
just what did you think of the way you
two were working out together and the
screens down low to get open and get the
looks that you were getting I mean we've
been doing this for years so it's
natural
it's not that we think we have to take
on the scoring low but when Kevin is not
out there we the balls gonna find us
little bit more because obviously you
know what he can do averaging 35 a game
and these postseason run but now we just
play our game
we don't put any extra pressure on
herself to carry the team that's three
questions right here last three
Michael Grange from Sports Net you guys
went on that nine now run after the
Raptors called timeout you're down six
we're a little surprised they called the
timeout and and what did you guys talk
about how did you guys gather yourself
in that in that timeout
well we've been down big before we've
been down for his quarters late in games
sorry
and I mean coach Kerr drew up a couple
gray sets and me and Steph just got
clean looks and you don't want to give
us too many of those cuz they'll go in
most the time be right here
Steve Ashburn nba.com um you guys
outscored them nine to two over those
final three minutes or so how much in
that that stretch are you thinking stops
as opposed to shots and that building
was ready to boil over
do you take some motivation or set a
section and just hushing things up yeah
our goal is to get them back on the
plane get them back to Oakland we owe
our fans one more game and Oracle and
[Music]
I'm sorry was the first part of the
question Oh shots I mean when you're on
the defensive end all you're thinking is
press up on your offensive player and
crash the board as far as possible we're
not even thinking about scoring when
you're on that side of the ball she just
got to take in one play at a time but
when we got back on the other side of
the ball we just wanted to get Steph in
a pick-and-roll and if they doubled him
just find the open man and luckily we
found each other last question here in
the next row back ichael a life side on
the left side okay all right so um okay
Kevin used to say people being wanted to
you know separate him and you guys and
he always got hit and he always the
target do you think today's a finally
showed that you guys actually together
as the team
I don't think today's showed if anyone
watched the last three years of
basketball you saw this man was the
files MVP back to back so all that those
Talking Heads who say we're better
without on that's just ludicrous like
that's crazy
this is the best play in the world you
could put him on the 30th best team
League and that's that team will make
the playoffs that's how a town city is
so we don't even pay any of that no mind
because with him we are really one that
I believe one of the greatest teams to
ever play without him were a really good
team but he's still coming around out
there like I said before one of the
greatest ever so
we don't pay that any attention because
that's just stupid it's stupid cuz he's
a warrior you saw what he did tonight he
sacrificed his health for us and we
dearly miss him I mean I was very
deflated to see him go out like I'm just
and pray for the guy and I know he'll be
back him is stronger
thank you